microsoft has sony a little worried
playstation is ditching a ps5 feature
and there's some pokemon news coming
microsoft's plan to acquire activision
blizzard is currently being scrutinized
by regulatory bodies across the world
and sony's official response to
questions from brazil's government has
been published according to those
documents sony believes that once
microsoft owns the call of duty
franchise as a part of the acquisition
it'll have the power to influence users
console choices via a vgc translation
sony said quote call of duty is so
popular that it influences users choice
of console and its community of loyal
users is entrenched enough that even if
a competitor had the budget to develop a
similar product it would not be able to
rival it now the funny thing about this
is that even though sony is worried
playstation has been using call of duty
to influence player choice for years now
by having exclusive and or early access
to content for example 2019's modern
warfare launched with a co-op spec op
survival mode as a ps4 exclusive feature
back in february microsoft reiterated
its intention to continue developing
activision franchises for competing
console platforms instead it would
continue supporting call of duty on
playstation quote beyond the existing
agreement and into the future microsoft
had previously confirmed that it would
honor any existing publishing agreements
especially this year's modern warfare 2
call of duty war zone 2 next year
hopefully and a new call of duty core
release late 2023. in other playstation
news sony is doing away with the
playstation 5's accolades this fall if
you didn't know accolades was a launch
feature on playstation 5 and players
could give medals like helpful welcoming
and good sport to others in multiplayer
games in theory sony implemented the
accolade system to reduce toxicity the
toxicity
but in practice nobody really knew the
system existed a fact that sony
acknowledged in the discontinuation
announcement so did you use the
accolades or was this your first time
hearing about it i remember knowing this
was a thing and then quickly forgetting
it until like
right now until this announcement me
reporting it so r.i.p i guess but okay
the time has come once again for news on
those monsters that we trap into tiny
balls and force into battle for our
enjoyment the pokemon company has
announced that a new pokemon presents
will be streamed on august 3rd at 6 am
pacific 9 am eastern on its youtube
channel the next games in the series
scarlet and violet will be the main
event of this week's presentation and
it's likely that the video will have a
few more pocket monsters to reveal
june's trailer showed off a mix of
returning faces and region exclusive
pokemon such as the adorable le trunk
that took the internet by storm with its
wholesome design so maybe this wednesday
we'll get to see a le chunk evolution
actually on second thought maybe we
don't need to see that because let's be
real for a second we're all going to
stop it from evolving so it can stay
looking the same as for the other games
that will be shown at wednesday's stream
there's a whole lot of pokemon projects
currently active ranging from mobile
games like pokemon unite and pokemon
masters as well as apps for the
franchise such as pokemon home but there
are only two things that i want to see
and hear about in the presentation and
that is a lot more information on the
co-op that's going to be in scarlet and
violet and pokemon sleep
where is it
is it is it cancelled is it coming out
can i have it right now
why do i want it let me know in the
comments why do i want it
you